welcome to this exclusive screening of  loki make some noise everyone  it feels great i have to say  i am loki i'm a god fasten your seat  belts because it's a real ride  it's a whole new chapter for loki i'm so  grateful to the fans i wouldn't be  standing here without them who is ready  to see the first episode of marvel  studios  this is the good part the president of  marvel studios  kevin feige hey guys  ladies and gentlemen owen wilson thank  you  what was it like working with tom  hiddleston excuse me  i think i heard my name it wouldn't be  the loki launch without a little bit of  mischief  you guys have seen episode one would you  like to see  episode two  [Applause]  what did you expect